Big-ears, basically, means folding even more surface area in, and that gives very, very high
sink rates. Really very, very high sink rates, even just in straight flight, and with a little
bit of roll and weight shift we can bring values into the double-digit range, so very
easily and without much physical strain.
But it's more of an advanced technique, so we only do this at the end
of training.
For completeness I want to show it to you as well, because it's another option
and really useful when you absolutely need to lose altitude.
The technique is basically identical to making little-ears, except that we now take two A-lines
into each hand.
So again, brakes stay in the hand, why — that's of course
for re-opening, so we always need to be a little bit ready for everything, that's why
we keep the brakes in our hands, then we go on the accelerator, again lightly
on the bar, fresh, and now the important thing: now we have to try to grab the outermost
A-line on the right and the one next to it, the next A-line, and we now must not
pull too low down.
So, not too close to the line-lock, because otherwise we'd pull the innermost A-line along with it and end up
with a full collapse, a front collapse.
And that's why we have to try to grab as high up as possible, well above the
line-lock, then first kink the lines and then pull down, and then we apply the bar.
If the ears are already folded in firmly, we can let our hands come up a bit and
set slightly less ear, so we can even adjust the size of the ears a little,
or even hold them at the position where we are, or we can keep them
and simply fix them, on the main riser, as close as possible. Then with weight shift
we can increase the sink rate even more, or not, just keep the speed steady,
but never with full bar applied as well.
And only once the ears are back out do we go fully out on the sink rate again.
It's actually fine, you just need to do it a few times, don't get scared, at the beginning it
folds in a lot of surface and that can leave you a bit shocked
at first, but we'll train it, do the whole thing a few times, and the key point is also that we
try to look up and check how much have I folded in. If it would be too much
and the wing is practically not properly open in the middle, we release the A-lines a bit
so we naturally get a bit more steering authority to actually steer the wing afterwards
and stay on heading and course.